I wasn't allowed to say this then but I
just don't care now here's a generic
intro to a clip we wanted to show you
it's interesting you know I've had
people the first time since 9/11 in the
war on terror people have been
commenting on social media that I
shouldn't say we when we talk about
America I wasn't allowed to say this
then but I just don't care now I am an
American and I report as an American and
I think about America's interests when I
support you know back on 9/11 they
wouldn't let us at ABC News wear a flag
pin I always thought that was wrong I'm
an American I'm worried about the
American hostages I'm worried about our
interests um and that's one aspect of
why I
care